tras días de trabajo incansable Los
rescatistas no tienen más esperanzas
encontrar sobrevivientes pero debajo del
barro y las ramas ven el cuerpo de una
víctima
cinco días después el derrumbe se han
encontrado más de 40 cuerpos pero mucha
gente sigue desaparecida para sus seres
queridos la espera es insoportable tres
familia res cercanos míos míos
y cinco personas que están desaparecidas
Y todavía ni siquiera aparecían en lista
Quiero comida yo creo que aparezcan mis
familiares de verdad el domingo se
decretó luto nacional por parte de las
autoridades luego de hacerse presente
allí el lunes el mandatario venezolano
Nicolás Maduro dio una nueva valoración
en la televisión Estatal y todavía hay
un número importante desaparecido
56 desaparecidos
estamos llegando casi a un centenar de
víctimas
fatales de
esta tragedia este desastre natural el
deslave se produjo el sábado Luego de
lluvias torrenciales en esta región del
centro Norte del país es el peor
desastre natural en Venezuela desde
principios del siglo una catástrofe
relacionada según los expertos al cambio
climático pero agravada por una
Urbanización descontrolada con viviendas
construidas en zonas de riesgo las
autoridades han habilitado alojamientos
de emergencia y han anunciado la
distribución de 300 toneladas de
alimentos